[Music]  do you know what makes a real hero it's  not the costumes the gadgets the cool  powers it's having your own movie and  that has always been my dream  what are you doing just giving the  people at the wall our movies not about  Wonder Woman it's about us the Teen  Titan Noah wants to see us full Wonder  Woman inspires people and we do not yes  Wonder Woman is great but I love Wonder  Woman narrator guy just do your thing  when the creators of Teen Titans go it's  a balance courage it's a thousand action  it's the superhero movie to end all  superhero movies  fully that wasn't a fart that was just  air leaving my butt which is a fart Teen  Titans go to the movies because if  Aquaman can get a movie anyone can  [Music]